LOT OF REACTION, GET ANALYSIS,
LOU DOBBS, DAN BONGINO TONIGHT,
BUT FIRST, IT’S AFTER 9:00 P.M.
AND OUR NATION’S CAPITAL, AND
THAT PROBABLY MEANS THAT
JOE BIDEN IS LIKELY FAST ASLEEP.
IT’S BEEN AN EXHAUSTING FEW DAYS
FOR JOE.
HE SIGNED A RECORD 40 EXECUTIVE
ORDERS AND ACTIONS INTO "LAW"
AFTER JUST NINE DAYS IN OFFICE.
IN OTHER WORDS, HE HAS TRIPLED
THE AMOUNT OF EXECUTIVE ORDERS
SIGNED BY TRUMP, OBAMA, AND BUSH
COMBINED AT THIS POINT IN THEIR
PRESIDENCIES.
NOW, INSTEAD OF THE UNITY THAT
WAS PROMISED, JOE IS LITERALLY
ACTING UNILATERALLY TO ENACT
EVERY ASPECT OF HIS RADICAL
SOCIALIST AGENDA, AND HE IS
DOING IT ALL WITH THE STROKE OF
A PEN AND ITS CONSEQUENCES ARE
SEVERE.
IT IS SO BAD, EVEN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" EDITORIAL
BOARD EVER SO GENTLY AND EVER SO
POLITELY ENCOURAGED BIDEN TO
EASE UP ON THE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS, AND AT LEAST TRY TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THERE ARE THREE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT.
YOU ARE THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
THEN WE HAVE THIS OTHER BRANCH,
THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH.
AND EVEN THIS EVER-SO-MILD
CRITICISM OF BIDEN, IT CAUSED
MANY ON THE RADICAL LEFT, THEY
BECAME UNGLUED COMPLETELY
UNHINGED.
HOW DARE "THE NEW YORK TIMES" DO
THAT!
SCORES OF THESE BLUE CHECK MARK
LIBERALS ON TWITTER LASHING OUT
AT "THE NEW YORK TIMES," ONE
FREQUENT MSDNC GUEST CALLING
THEM COWARDLY, AND OTHER
LEFT-WING ACTIVISTS CALLING
THEM.
BY THE WAY, WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE
BUSY FIGHTING EACH OTHER, JUST
LET THE FLIGHT GO ON.
HOW DARE THE TIMES WRITE
ANYTHING OTHER THAN GLOWING
PRAISE FOR THE DEAR COMRADES AND
WEAK LEADER.
OF COURSE, THIS OP-ED DOES PALE
GREATLY IN COMPARISON TO HOW
THEY COVERED DONALD TRUMP AND
OTHER CONSERVATIVES IN HIS FIRST
FEW WEEKS OF OFFICE.
ONE HEADLINE READS, "MR. TRUMP’S
THREAT TO EUROPE’S SECURITY POST
WOULD.
ANOTHER QUOTE,
"PRESIDENT TRUMP’S RECKLESS
SHAME GAME."
SEVEN MONTHS INTO HIS TERM, THE
TIMES RAN AN ARTICLE ENTITLED
"THE FAILING TRUMP PRESIDENCY."
WOW, THAT WAS QUICK.
AND SADLY, THIS IS ABOUT SO MUCH
MORE OF THE MEDIA BIAS, BECAUSE
WITH THE STROKE OF A PEN, THAT’S
IT, A PEN, BIDEN’S LITANY OF
EXECUTIVE ORDERS ARE CAUSING
REAL, SERIOUS, LIFE-CHANGING
PROBLEMS FOR TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF HARDWORKING MEN AND WOMEN,
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS, RIGHT HERE
AND RIGHT NOW, THEY ARE
SUFFERING.
THOUSANDS ALREADY RECEIVING
THEIR PINK SLIPS AFTER JOE
CANCELED THE KEYSTONE XL
PIPELINE.
STOP BORDER WALL CONSTRUCTION.
UP TO 58,000 MORE COULD SOON BE
UNEMPLOYED BECAUSE OF THIS NEW
BAN ON DRILLING ON FEDERAL
LANDS.
A LOT MORE TO FOLLOW.
THESE ARE HIGH-PAYING, YES,
BLUE-COLLAR, HIGH SKILL JOBS,
GONE, NOT EASILY, IF AT ALL,
REPLACEABLE, ALL WITH THE STROKE
OF THE FRAIL, WEAK, JOE BIDEN
HAND.
A PEN IN HIS HAND.
SOCIALIST CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ, SHE
THINKS THIS IS GREAT!
WHAT A GREAT DAY!
I’M NOT MAKING IT UP.
>> NOW, I’M FEELING
EXTRAORDINARILY ENCOURAGED, AND
I THINK THAT THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S EXECUTIVE
ORDERS COMMUNICATE A LOT.
ONE IS THAT IT REALLY
COMMUNICATES THAT HE MEANT WHAT
HE SAID ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL,
THAT HE WOULD MAKE CLIMATE
CHANGE A CENTRAL PRIORITY OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THAT HE
CONSIDERS THAT NOT JUST A
NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT, BUT
FRANKLY, A GLOBAL MATTER THAT IT
IS.
BUT IT ALSO REALLY -- IT ALSO
REALLY SIGNIFIES A GOOD-FAITH
OPENNESS AND RELATIONSHIP TO
THOSE ACTIVIST COMMUNITIES.
>> Sean: CONGRESSWOMAN, WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT, YOUR GREEN NEW
DEAL POLICIES, BRAGGING ABOUT
JOE’S AND ACTING, THEY
RESULTED IN GREAT AMERICAN
WORKERS, YOUR FELLOW AMERICANS,
GETTING FIRED.
TELL ME, WHERE ARE THEY GOING TO
WORK NEXT WEEK?
AND HOW ARE THEY GOING TO PAY
THEIR BILLS?
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO PUT FOOD
ON THEIR TABLE, OR PAY THEIR
RENT, OR MAKE MORTGAGE PAYMENTS,
OR CAR OR TRUCK PAYMENTS?
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO PAY FOR
HEALTH CARE, OR INSURANCE, OR
DAY-TO-DAY LIVING?
DO YOU EVEN CARE?
BECAUSE I SEE ZERO COMPASSION
FROM YOU AND JOHN KERRY AND
JOE BIDEN AND PETE BUTTIGIEG,
AND LET’S SEE, GRANHOLM AND THE
REST OF YOU.
HARDWORKING, LAW-ABIDING,
TAXPAYING MEN AND WOMEN, WORKING
MEN AND WOMEN COME OUT OF WORK,
WITH ALL OF THE PROMISES -- WE
WANT YOU TO GET NEW UNION JOBS.
WELL, THE HIGH-PAYING JOBS THAT
DISAPPEAR, FOR EXAMPLE, AND
CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO-CORTEZ’S OW
REMEMBER, SHE RAN AMAZON RIGHT
OUT OF HER DISTRICT.
THE WORLD IS ENDING, AND THE NEW
GREEN DEAL IS FAR MORE
IMPORTANT.
SHE SAYS THE WORLD IS ENDING.
AND TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICAN JOBS.
THE ONWARD MARCH FOR SOCIALISM
MUST BE OUR TOP PRIORITY.
MAY BE CONGRESSWOMAN
OCASIO-CORTEZ ACTUALLY THINKS
THAT SHE IS SAVING THE PLANET.
AND BY THE WAY, ONE OUT OF WORK
AMERICAN AT A TIME, RIGHT?
IN REALITY, THIS GREEN NEW DEAL
SOCIALIST AGENDA IS HURTING OUR
FELLOW AMERICANS.
IT’S HURTING THE COUNTRY.
AND BY THE WAY, IT WILL HURT THE
PLANET.
LET ME TELL YOU HOW.
THE WORLD IS STILL, WHETHER YOU
LIKE IT OR NOT, RELIANT, THE
LIFEBLOOD OF THE WORLD’S ECONOMY
IS ENERGY, OIL, GAS, COAL, AND
GUESS WHAT?
PEOPLE WILL STILL BE BUYING IT,
AMERICANS WILL STILL BE USING
IT, AND GUESS WHAT, WE WILL HAVE
TO NOW GET MORE OF IT FROM,
WELL, IN A LOT OF COUNTRIES THAT
WE VIEW AS HOSTILE REGIMES,
RUSSIA, IRAN, CHINA, COUNTRIES
IN THE MIDDLE EAST THAT HATE OUR
GUTS, THOSE WOULD BE COUNTRIES
THAT DON’T REALLY GIVE A RIP
ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT, EITHER,
IN OTHER WORDS, HOSTILE REGIMES
RUN BY HOSTILE ACTORS AROUND THE
WORLD, THEY ARE GOING TO GET
RICH AND POWERFUL.
THEY ARE DOING BACK FLIPS.
THEY WANT TO SEND YOU THANK YOU
CARDS.
AND POLLUTION WILL LIKELY ALSO
GET WORSE.
THIS DOESN’T SEEM TO MATTER TO
ANYBODY IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, ANYONE
SUPPORTING THIS MADNESS.
FOR EXAMPLE, BIDEN SPECIAL
CLIMATE ENVOY, JOHN KERRY, HE
HAS LONG FLOWN ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
HE OWNS A BIG PRIVATE ON JET,
CAUSING, BY THE WAY, HIS OWN
MASSIVE CARBON FOOTPRINT.
NOW, CONGRESSWOMAN
OCASIO-CORTEZ, PERHAPS YOU
SHOULD ASK YOUR FELLOW CLIMATE
CHANGE SUPPORTER, JOHN KERRY,
WHO HAS NO PROBLEMS TELLING
PEOPLE YOU ARE OUT OF WORK, THIS
IS MORE IMPORTANT, MAY BE THAT
JET POLLUTES MORE IN A GIVEN
YEAR THAN MOST AMERICANS WILL IN
THEIR ENTIRE LIVES!
NOW, I THINK MAYBE YOU SHOULD
ASK JOHN KERRY IF HE CARES ABOUT
THE PLANET, WHY DOESN’T HE LEAD
BY EXAMPLE?
HOW ABOUT HE ORDERS THAT HIS
PRIVATE JET BE GROUNDED, AND IN
FAIRNESS, DON’T SELL IT, BECAUSE
IT WOULD STILL BE A CARBON
FOOTPRINT, HE SHOULD HAVE IT
DISASSEMBLED, SO IT CAN NEVER BE
USED AGAIN, THEN YOU CAN RECYCLE
ALL THE MATERIALS.
AND WHILE WE ARE AT IT, ALL OF
BIDEN CABINET OFFICIALS, THEY
SHOULD STOP USING THE PRIVATE
JETS, AND YOU MIGHT NOT KNOW
THIS, BUT YOU, THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYER, PAY FOR IT.
YOU FOOT THE BILL FOR WHAT IS A
FLEET, A MASSIVE FLEET OF
PRIVATE JETS AND AIRCRAFT USED
BY FEDERAL OFFICIALS AND CABINET
MEMBERS.
NOW, THINK ABOUT IT.
IF WE ARE CURRENTLY FACING THIS
GREAT CLIMATE CRISIS AND
CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO-CORTEZ’S
RIGHT, WE ONLY HAVE 12 YEARS,
AND IT’S THAT SERIOUS, THAT OIL
AND GAS WORKERS ARE GOING TO
LOSE THEIR HIGH-PAYING CAREER
JOBS AND LOSE THEIR HEALTH CARE
AND MAYBE LOSE THEIR HOMES, NOT
BE ABLE TO SAVE FOR THEIR
FUTURES, SEND THEIR KIDS TO
COLLEGE, THEN SHOULDN’T BIDEN
OFFICIALS LEAD BY EXAMPLE, STOP
FLYING ON THE PRIVATE JETS THAT
WE, THE AMERICAN TAXPAYERS, ARE
PAYING FOR?
NOW, I’M WAITING FOR
CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO-CORTEZ,
JOHN KERRY, PETE BUTTIGIEG,
JOE BIDEN, JENNIFER GRANHOLM,
I’M WAITING FOR THEIR ANSWER.
I WANT JOE TO ISSUE AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER GROUNDING THE ENTIRE
GOVERNMENT FLEET THAT WE, THE
TAXPAYERS, ARE PAYING FOR.
THIS KIND OF HEARTLESS HYPOCRISY
IS DISGUSTING!
IF YOU WANT TO BE LEADERS, AND
BY EXAMPLE.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT WE, THE
HARDWORKING MEN AND WOMEN IN
THIS COUNTRY.
MORE SPECIFICALLY, THOSE THAT
LOST, AGAIN, GOOD PAYING, WELL
SKILLED, CAREER JOBS.
LET THEM WORK ELSEWHERE,
JOHN KERRY EXCLAIMED, YOU KNOW,
SAYING.
IS A WORTHY SACRIFICE.
A WORTHY SACRIFICE, ACCORDING TO
JENNIFER GRANHOLM, WHERE IS HER
SACRIFICE?
AND JUST GO OUT AND FIND ANOTHER
UNION JOB, SAYS THE EVER REALLY
EXPERIENCED MAYOR PETE.
MAYOR OF SOUTH BEND.
THE PARTY WHO CLAIMS TO HAVE A
MONOPOLY ON COMPASSION FOR ALL
OF US, I’M NOT SEEING MUCH
COMPASSION AT ALL FOR ALL THESE
HARDWORKING AMERICANS THAT ARE
ANXIOUS AND CAN SLEEP TONIGHT,
WORRIED WHERE THE NEXT PAYCHECK
IS GOING TO COME FROM, AND
WONDERING WHETHER OR NOT IT WILL
EVER BE ABLE TO REPLACE THE GOOD
JOBS YOU JUST TOOK FROM THEM.
AND REMEMBER, THESE JOB KILLING
POLICIES DIDN’T GO THROUGH
CONGRESS.
STROKE OF A PEN, THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS UNEMPLOYED, BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN, LISTENING TO THE
RADICAL LEFT THAT CONTROLS HIM.
HE DID IT WITH A STROKE OF A
PEN.
A FEW MONTHS AGO ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL, THERE WAS BIDEN, HE WAS
CLAIMING THAT GOVERNING BY
EXECUTIVE FIAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT DICTATORS DO.
NO, WE’VE GOT TO GET THE VOTES,
HE SAID.
THIS IS A DEMOCRACY.
WHAT HAPPENED, JOE?
IN CASE YOU FORGOT.
WHICH IS LIKELY.
I WILL REMIND YOU.
>> I’VE GOT TO GET THE VOTES.
I’VE GOT TO GET THE VOTES.
THAT’S WHY, YOU KNOW, THE ONE
THING -- I HAVE THIS STRANGE
NOTION, WE ARE A DEMOCRACY.
SOME OF MY REPUBLICAN FRIENDS
AND SOME OF MY DEMOCRATIC
FRIENDS EVEN OCCASIONALLY SAY,
WELL, IF YOU CAN’T GET THE
VOTES, BY EXECUTIVE ORDER,
YOU’RE GOING TO DO SOMETHING.
THINGS YOU CAN’T DO BY EXECUTIVE
ORDER, MUST TO DICTATOR.
WE ARE A DEMOCRACY.
ANY CONSENSUS.
>> Sean: MORE THAN THREE TIMES
THE NUMBER OF EXECUTIVE ORDERS
IN ALL THREE OF HIS PREVIOUS
PRESIDENTS.
BIDEN’S PRESS SECRETARY
APPARENTLY TRYING TO REWRITE
HISTORY.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK AT THE SLIDE.
SPEAK [INSTINCT]
>> WELL, ROBIN, SURE THIS WAS
NOT YOUR INTENTION, BUT I THINK
IT OF THE PRESIDENTS COMPETENCE
OUT OF CONTEXT.
HE WAS ASKED ABOUT TAX REFORM
AND WHAT HE COULD DO THAT DURING
THE INTERVIEW WITH GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS.
I THINK THE QUESTION, IT’S
IMPORTANT CONTEXT FOR EVERYBODY,
AND HE SAID NO.
AND ALSO DURING AN INTERVIEW
WITH COLUMNIST BACK IN DECEMBER,
HE DIDN’T THINK EXECUTIVE ACTION
SHOULD BE USED FOR EVERYTHING,,
AND THAT CERTAINLY HIS POINT OF
VIEW.
>> Sean: THREE TIMES THE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS IN THE SAME
TIME FRAME THAT BUSH 43, OBAMA,
AND DONALD TRUMP.
JEN PSAKI, I THOUGHT YOU
PROMISED YOU WEREN’T GOING TO
LIE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT WOULD BE, YEAH, THE
FACT-CHECK MY LIST.
AND OF COURSE, BIDEN’S 40 AND
COUNTING EXECUTIVE ORDERS DON’T
EXACTLY SPELL UNITY, DO THEY?
JUST TODAY, HE SIGNED OFF ON AN
ORDER BANNING, GET THIS, TOP
PRIORITY, THE TERM "RHINOVIRUS"
IN HIS WHITE HOUSE, OR "WUHAN
VIRUS" FROM BEING USED AT ANY
FEDERAL LEVEL.
I DON’T KNOW WHY.
EVEN THOUGH CHINA AND WUHAN, WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT GEOGRAPHICAL
LOCATIONS.
YOU KNOW, EVEN THOUGH CHINA,
HATE TO SAY IT, JOE, THEY WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE VIRUS.
REMEMBER, THEY PUT THE TRAVEL
BAN IN EFFECT, COULDN’T TRAVEL
OUT OF WUHAN TO THE REST OF
CHINA, COULDN’T TRAVEL FROM THE
REST OF CHINA TO WUHAN, WE WOULD
TRAVEL FROM WUHAN ANYWHERE IN
THE WORLD.
AND BY THE WAY, WHERE IS THE
ORDER BANNING THE TERM, I GUESS,
"GERMAN MEASLES" IS NEXT, "THE
NEW COVID, SOUTH AFRICAN VARIANT
OF COVID-19."
BUT HEY, WHEN YOU WILL BY
EXECUTIVE FIAT, I GUESS FACTS
DON’T MATTER.
CERTAINLY, NEITHER DO AMERICAN
WORKERS.
THEY WAKE UP, WORK HARD, PLAY BY
THE RULES, OBEY THE LAWS, PAY
THEIR TAXES, RAISE THEIR KIDS,
PUT IN -- WAKE UP, SHOVEL COFFEE
DOWN THEIR THROAT, MAKE KIDS
LUNCH FOR SCHOOL, RACED
OFF TO WORKS, DO THE 12-14 HOURS
COME HELP THEIR KIDS WITH
HOMEWORK, THEY FEED THEM, THEY
PUT THEM TO BED, THEY LITERALLY
PASS OUT EXHAUSTED EVERY DAY.